with Romania the United States and
Romania have gotten along better than
ever before so I want to thank you for
that and we have a big trade business
going on to be honest with you we have
we do a lot of trade with Romania and
they're very talented people we buy they
buy and you have a lot of Romanian
people in the United States very
importantly and they're tremendous
people they work very hard very very
successful how many do you have any no
it's it's you know has anyone figured
that out we have quite a lot of stuff
for maintenance in this space I think I
know most of them large population and
but they and they love Romania - I will
tell you that they never forgot Romania
they're very much inclined that way and
that's a good thing well I want to thank
you mr. president for being here - great
honor thank you very much thank you so
much mr. president
great pleasure to be here mr. say
something yeah what just underline that
it's great to be back here with you mr.
president and now we have the
opportunity to talk about a very good
prestigious partnership and under your
strong leadership we progress and we
will continue doing so this is very
important for us and I think we are on
the right path and that thank you for
them I think we are on the right path a
lot of interesting things happening also
in your country but we appreciate the
trade and we're going to have a big
meeting in a little while after this
we're gonna have a private meeting then
we're gonna have a meeting in the
Cabinet Room with a lot of your
officials and we look forward to that
yes any question is general
mr. president what's what sort of
contingency steps or plans as the White
House thinking about to stave off any
kind of economic slowdown we've heard
that there's been some talk of the
payroll tax cut kicked around some other
tax cuts you were talking about a
cutting Fed rate quantitative easing
what are you looking at well I'd like to
see a cut in the Fed rate because that
should have happened a long time ago I
think they're being very tardy and not
doing it and not having done it sooner
they raised too quickly and you know
I've been quite vocal on that they also
did quantitative tightening which was
ridiculous and so and despite that you
know if you look I guess you could call
it normalize but if you look our economy
is doing fantastically and if you take a
look at the previous administration they
weren't paying interest they had no
interest rates they had loosening that
type thing and frankly it's a big
difference in our economy is incredible
our jobs you look at the jobs market but
you have to be proactive and so we
really need a Fed cut rate because if
you look at what's going on with the
Europe European Union as an example
they're cutting you take a look at
Germany what they're doing and what
they're paying I mean they're actually
doing something inverse they've never
seen nobody's ever seen it before we
have to at least keep up to an extent so
right now we're paying a very much
higher rate of interest and we didn't
follow the world and generally speaking
that's okay but you can't have that much
of a disparity so we're looking for a
rate cut we could be really greatly
helped if the Fed would do its job and
do a substantial rate cut also they were
doing quantitative typing very bad to do
they should do easing actual easing no
tightening or a minimum they should be
doing nothing about that but they have
to do a rate cut the other thing is yeah
we're looking at various tax reductions
but I'm looking at that all the time
anyway tax reductions that's one of the
reasons we're in such a strong economic
position we're right now the number one
country anywhere in the world by far as
an economy Europe's got a lot of
problems and Asia's got a lot of
problems you look at China China's had
the worst year they've had in twenty
years and they want to make a deal with
us but I can tell you I'm not ready to
make a deal unless they're going to make
the right kind of a deal I'm not ready
to make a deal so I don't I don't know
but I will say this something will
happen
maybe soon and maybe a little bit later
but China very much wants to make a deal
we've heard again potential cutting
payroll tax indexing capital gains what
would you accept well you know we've
been talking about indexing for a long
time and many people like indexing and
it could be done very simple it can be
done directly by me and so we've been
looking at that as you probably have
heard I can do it directly so we're
talking about indexing and we're always
looking at the capital gains tax payroll
tax we're looking at I would love to do
something on capital gains we'll talk it
about that that it's a big deal goes
through Congress payroll tax is
something that we think about and a lot
of people would like to see that and
that very much affects the working the
workers of our country and we have a lot
of workers right now by the way we have
more people working today than we've
ever had before in the history of our
country we have almost a hundred and
sixty million people working today I
think the word recession is a word
that's inappropriate because it's just a
word that the the certain people I'm
going to be kind certain people and the
media are trying to build up because
they'd love to see a recession we're
very far from a recession in fact if the
Fed would do its job I think would have
a tremendous spurt of growth a
tremendous for the Fed is
psychologically very important less so
actually but very psychologically
important and if the Fed would do its
job which it said really done very
poorly over the last year and a half you
would see a burst of growth like you've
never seen before and that would be
lowering interest rates and maybe
putting some if you
look at what China is doing if you look
at what Germany is doing if you look at
what so many countries are doing putting
some money in because we want to compete
with these other countries so I think
that we actually are set for a
tremendous surge of growth if the Fed
would do its job that's a big if
frankly the Fed should be cutting and I
would say they should say at a minimum a
hundred basis points over a period of
time not at one time but over a period
of time well I'm not talking about I'm
not talking about doing anything at this
moment but indexing is something that a
lot of people have liked for a long time
and it's something that would be very
easy to do and a lot of people have been
talking about indexing for many years
and it's something that I am certainly
thinking about I can say that a majority
of the people in the white house at the
level that does this kind of thing they
like indexing so it is something I'm
thinking about payroll taxes I've been
thinking about payroll taxes for a long
time whether or not we do it now or not
is it's not being done because of
recession because we are legitimately if
we had a cut in interest rates by the
Fed if they would do their job properly
and if they would do a meaningful cut
because they raised too fast you would
see growth like you've not seen ever in
this country now if you go from the
election that great November 8th date if
you go from November 9th to present
you're talking about almost a 60%
increase in the stock market you're
talking about unemployment numbers that
are the lowest in history in many
categories and overall almost the lowest
ever in the history of our country I
think it was 1969 and we are set to
surpass that number I mean our country
is doing very well when I spoke to the
president we were just walking in and he
said congratulations on the great
success of your economy and you can't
and I appreciated that but I'll cut you
sing very well it's one of the things
we'll be talking about today I assume
you might be bringing their that but
it's something we'll talk about the g7
would you like to have platinum ear puts
him back in the g7 make of the g8 again
so it was the g8 for a long time and now
it's the g7 and a lot of the time we
talk about we talk about Russia we're
talking about Russia cuz I've gone to
numerous g7 meetings and I guess
President Obama because Putin outsmarted
him President Obama thought it wasn't a
good thing to have Russia in so he
wanted Russia out but I think it's much
more appropriate to have Russia in it
should be the g8 because a lot of the
things we talk about have to do with
Russia so I could certainly see it being
the g8 again and if somebody would make
that motion
I would certainly be disposed to think
about it very favorably but as you know
for most of the time it was the g8 and
included Russia and President Obama
didn't want Russia in because he got
outsmarted well that's not the way it
really should work
[Music]
yeah we've spent a lot of time on it
we've spent a lot of time discussing it
already our countries have been
discussing it and we're going to we're
taking it up today at a very important
meeting right after this dude do you
like the idea it sounds like you like
the idea that the waiver do you like the
idea okay no it's something we're
thinking about we are in touch we're
talking to various representatives of
Venezuela
we're helping Venezuela as much as we
can we're staying out of it but we are
helping it and it needs a lot of help
it's an incredible tribute to something
bad happening and there's something bad
is socialism and it's amazing because 15
years ago is one of the wealthiest
countries now it's one of the poorest
countries it has oil reserves has a lot
of things going but it's it's a very sad
thing what's happened they don't have
water they don't have food and we are
helping a lot we are talking to the
representatives at different levels of
Venezuela yes I don't want to say who
but we are talking at a very high level
so I spoke with Boris Johnson I think
he's gonna be a great prime minister I
think he's gonna do a fantastic job I've
known him a lot of people know that we
have a very good relationship I think
he'll be far superior I think he'll do
something that will be a variable I
think he's going to be very important
for the UK I think he's gonna be very
important dealing with the European
Union I hate to say this to you but
dealing with the European Union is very
difficult they drive a hard bargain
they're represented by jean-claude who
is a friend of mine but he's a tough man
he's a very very tough man as a great
negotiator and we have all the cards in
this country because all would have to
do is tax their cars and they would give
us anything they wanted because they
send millions of Mercedes over the
send millions of BMWs over but we're
talking to the European Union we're
gonna see if we can work something out
but but I will say this dealing with the
UK they have not treated the UK very
well they that's a very tough bargain
they're driving the European Union it's
a very tough bargain and I think that UK
has the right man in charge right now
the right person in charge in the form
of force we're talking to the government
of Afghanistan we're talking to the
Taliban and we're talking to others and
we're looking at different things we've
been there for 18 years it's ridiculous
we have taken it down a notch
we've worth about 13,000 people right
now there are 10,000 Americans NATO has
some troops there too by the way and
we're having good discussions we'll see
what happens we'll see what happens look
it's 18 years where like we're not
really fighting we're a almost more of a
police force over there it's been so
many years but we're like a police force
and we're not supposed to be a police
force and as I've said I'll say it any
number of times and this is not using
nuclear we could win that war in a week
if we wanted to fight it but I'm not
looking to kill 10 million people I'm
not looking to kill 10 million Afghan
because that's what would have to happen
and I'm not looking to do that but it's
a war that has been going on for almost
19 years now and frankly it's ridiculous
but with that being said it's a
dangerous place and we have to always
keep an eye on it I'd like to look at
various alternatives one of the
alternatives is going on right now we're
talking about a plan I don't know
whether or not the plan is going to be
acceptable acceptable to me and maybe
it's not going to be acceptable to them
but we are talking we have good talks
going and we'll see what happens this is
more than other presidents have done
but we have brought it down we are
bringing some of our troops back but we
have to have a presence yes could you
clarify your position on enhanced
background checks after El Paso and
Dayton you seem to be fully in support
of enhanced measures when you were
leaving Bedminster you seem to suggest
that we already do have strong
background laws which a lot of people
read as you dialing bathroom and I'm not
doing that to be cute we have very very
strong background checks right now but
we have sort of missing areas and areas
that don't complete the whole circle and
we're looking at different things and I
have to tell you that it is a mental
problem and I've said it a hundred times
it's not the gun that pulls the trigger
it's the person that pulls the trigger
these are sick people and it is also
that kind of a problem and we're looking
at mental institutions which we used to
have like as an example where I come
from in New York they closed up almost
all of their mental institutions or many
of them and those people just went onto
the streets and they did it for
budgetary reasons well New York is not
unique they've done that in many places
right now there 2,000 Americans
NATO has some troops there too by the
way and we're having good discussions
we'll see what happens we'll see what
happens
look it's 18 years we're like we're not
really fighting we're a almost more of a
police force over there it's been so
many years but we're like a police force
and we're not supposed to be a police
force and as I've said I'll say it any
number of times and this is not using
nuclear we could win that war in a week
if we wanted to fight it but I'm not
looking to kill 10 million people I'm
not looking to kill 10 million Afghans
because that's what would have to happen
and I'm not looking to do that but it's
a war that has been going on for almost
19 years now and frankly it's ridiculous
but with that being said it's a
dangerous place and we have to always
keep an eye on it I'd like to look at
various alternatives one of the
alternatives is going on right now we're
talking about a plan I don't know
whether or not how the plan is going to
be acceptable acceptable to me and maybe
it's not going to be acceptable to them
but we are talking we have good talks
going and we'll see what happens this is
more than other presidents have done but
we have brought it down we are bringing
some of our troops back but we have to
have a presence yes could you clarify
your position on enhanced background
checks after El Paso and date and you
seem to be fully in support of enhanced
measures when you were leaving
Bedminster you seem to suggest that we
already do have strong background laws
which a lot of people read as you
dialing back with us I mean I'm not
doing that to be cute we have very very
strong background checks right now but
we have sort of missing areas and areas
that don't complete the whole circle and
we're looking at different things and I
have to tell you that it is a mental
problem and I've said it a hundred times
it's not the gun that pulls the trigger
it's the person that pulls the trigger
these are sick people and it is also
that kind of a problem
and we're looking at mental institutions
which we used to have like as an example
where I come from in New York they
closed up almost all of their mental
institutions or many of them and those
people just went onto the streets and
they did it for budgetary reasons well
New York is not unique they've done that
in many places I'm not going to get into
that but we are in very meaningful
discussions with the Democrats and I
think the Republicans are very unified
we are very strong in our second
amendment the Democrats are not strong
at all in the second amendment I would
say they're weak on the second amendment
and we have to be careful of that the
Democrats would I believe I think they'd
give up the second amendment and the
people that a lot of the people that put
me where I am are strong believers in
the second amendment and I am also and
we have to be very careful about that
you know they call it the slippery slope
and all of a sudden everything gets
taken away we're not going to let that
happen
[Music]
well I hope so because we have good
results and I want to share those with
president from what is your question so
nice to have a question about Romania
sure I will sure I will of course I will
but I think that this is a man that can
solve the corruption problem in Romania
and he's made big strides from what I
hear I haven't been there recently but
he's made very big strides and I think
he's the man that can solve the
corruption problem there are a number of
really terrific countries like Romania
but they have a tremendous corruption
problem and I've heard you've made
tremendous progress
I need still support cutting well we're
looking at it and we're looking at it in
different ways and we're talking to
Republicans and Democrats about it and
certain things we can save and certain
things it probably could be you know a
penny wise maybe it's a penny wise we'll
see but we are looking at it and we have
some things that are on the table very
much and we'll let you know over the
next probably sooner their week well you
know just got an award in an endorsement
yesterday from a a the exact group and a
group they gave you saw that they gave
me the endorsement yesterday and I was
very honored to is it log cabin the log
cabin group and I was very honored to
receive it know I've done very well with
that community some of my biggest
supporters are of that community and I
think they and I talk to them a lot
about it I think I've done really very
well with that community as you know
Peter Thiel and so many others they're
there with me all the way and they like
the job I'm doing and I just got a big
endorsement from the log cabin group
yeah
well well ok let me let me tell you
something
number one we're doing very well as an
economy but somebody had to take China
on you know I read and I see so much and
I read so much and I'll see these
economists say oh give up give up on
China give up China's been ripping this
country off for 25 years for longer than
that and it's about time whether it's
good for our country or bad for our
country short term long term it's
imperative that somebody does this
because our country cannot continue to
pay China 500 billion dollars a year
because stupid people are running it so
I don't mind this question whether it's
good or bad short term is irrelevant we
have to solve the problem with China
because they're taking out 500 billion
dollars a year plus and that doesn't
include intellectual property theft and
other things and also national security
so I am doing this whether it's good or
bad for your your statement about oh
will we fall into a recession for two
months okay
the fact is somebody had to take China
and my life would be a lot easier if I
didn't take China on but I like doing it
because I have to do it and we're
getting great results China said the
worst year they've had in 27 years and a
lot of people saying the worst year
they've had in 54 years okay and frankly
I don't want that to happen
but it does put us in a good negotiating
position doesn't it and China wants to
make a deal and that's good but they
have to make a deal that's fair to us it
can't be a deal that's not fair to us
and you should be happy that I'm
fighting this and I'm fighting this
battle because somebody had to do it we
couldn't let this code I don't even
think it's sustainable to let go on what
was happening they were stealing all of
our intellectual property ideas the
theft was incredible they call it
intellectual property theft and they
value it at 300 a billion dollars a year
who knows how they value it I know how
to value dollars I don't know how to
value intellectual property theft but
they have experts that say it's at least
300 million dollarsí and where they
steal it somebody had to do something
with China Obama should have done it
Bush should have done it
Clinton should have done it they all
should have done it nobody did it I'm
doing it so what do you say oh my trade
deals are causing them my trade deals
aren't causing a problem this is
something that had to be done the only
difference is I'm doing it I could be
sitting here right now with the stock
market that would be up 10,000 points
higher if I didn't want to do it but I
think we have no choice but to do it and
a lot of people that really know people
that love our country they're saying
thank you very much for taking it on and
we're winning because they're having the
worst year they've had in decades and
it's only going to get worse China's
lost two million jobs in the last month
and a half because they're moving the
people the companies are moving to
non-tariff countries they've lost over
two million jobs in a very short period
of time they're going to lose a lot more
jobs and if I didn't help certain
companies they're American companies
like Apple for a very short period of
time I may help them only till they do
what they have to do which is probably
moved from China because this would be
very short-term if I didn't help them
they would I mean they would be they
would have a big problem here's the
thing somebody had to take on what China
was doing to the United States
economically we're winning big I took it
on and it should have been done by
previous presidents but I took it on and
I'm happy to do it because it had to be
done and the smart people say thank you
very much and the dumb people have no
idea and then you have the political
people and they go with the wind but
they all know even Senator Schumer said
Wow Trump's doing a great job with China
I couldn't believe that but Schumer
thinks I'm doing the right thing and
he's doing the right thing by saying it
because he knows that China was a big
economic threat and they were taking all
of that money that they were making from
us and they were building planes and
ships and lots of other things and we
can't let that happen
there is a new study out of Australia
that suggests with the current Chinese
military posture in the South the South
China Sea into Pacific region he could
wipe out most US bases within a number
of hours is that something that keeps
you up at night
well nothing keeps me up at night I'll
tell you we could wipe out anything we
well we have the most powerful in the
world and when I came in two and a half
years ago we were in a very bad position
now we're in a very strong position we
had seven hundred billion dollars then
seven hundred and sixteen billion and
then seven hundred and thirty eight
billion dollars we have the strongest
military in the world right now and
we're getting very close to finishing
that whole rebuilding we've rebuilt the
military right now there's nobody that's
even close to us militarily not even
close so the Chinese military now
because they pay a price that they
wouldn't want to pay somebody that's
being put up and respected very much to
Russia yeah
very respected well I know that Mike
Pompeo likes him very much and he's very
respected he could very well be Taliban
does not respect the government the
Afghan government they have no respect
for the Afghan government and I
understand that and I know that and they
haven't been exactly getting along for a
long period of time but we've been a
peacekeeper there in a way for 19 years
and at a certain point you have to say
that's long enough I go to Walter Reed
and I see young men that step on a bomb
and they lose their legs they lose their
Rob's in some case they lose both in
their face on top of it and they're
living and again we could win that but
you know I don't want to do
what we would have to do to win it I
think most people agree with me on that
right now what we're doing is we're
negotiating with the government and
we're negotiating with the Taliban and
we'll see what happens from it what's
coming from it I will say this the
Taliban would like to stop fighting us
they would like to stop fighting us
they've lost a lot but we'll see what
happens and remember it's a tough place
the Soviet Union became Russia because
of Afghanistan that's what happened very
simple they became Russia because of
Afghanistan somebody would say oh well
would Russia go in I said if they want
to let them I think they tried that
before however didn't work out too well
nobody can be trusted we could be a
world in this world I think nobody can
be trusted but could we be back to where
we were pre 9/11 with the Taliban in
completely that's what we have to watch
and we'll always have intelligence that
will always have somebody there but you
can say that about a lot of places John
you know doesn't have to be that sector
but that does seem to be the Harvard
University of terrorism okay it seems to
be and we'll always have somebody there
and if the Taliban were were really
right and what they're saying they would
stop that from happening because they
could stop that from happening very
easily well they've been having this
these talks for hundreds of years even
under different names but this is but
it's Kashmir and Kashmir is a very
complicated place
you have the Hindus and you have the
Muslims and I wouldn't say they get
along so great and that's what you have
right now and you have millions of
people that want to be ruled by others
and maybe on both sides and you have two
countries that haven't gotten along well
for a long time and frankly it's a very
explosive situation I spoke to Prime
Minister Khan I spoke with yesterday
also Prime Minister Modi that both
friends of mine they great
people they're great people and they
love their countries and they're in a
very tough situation Kashmir is a very
tough situation and you know we're
talking about this has been going on for
decades decades shooting I don't mean
shooting like shooting a rifle I mean
like major shooting of howitzers of you
know of heavy arms and it's been going
on for a long period of time but I get
along really well with both of them as
you know Prime Minister Khan was here
just recently and I was with I'm going
to be with Prime Minister Modi I'll be
with him over the weekend
in France so you know I think we're
helping the situation but there's
tremendous problems between those two
countries as you know and I will do the
best I can to mediate or do something a
great relationship with both of them but
they are not exactly friends at this
moment complicated situation a lot has
to do with religion religions a
complicated subject congresswoman Omar
yesterday said that the United States
should rethink its policy of aid toward
Israel after she and congresswoman
believe were denied entry congresswoman
to leave but was later allowed to
command but she decided not to should
there be any change in US aid to Israel
no and you should see the horrible
things that Talib has said about Israel
and ASE plus three that's what I call it
ASU just take a oc+ three and you should
see the things that the four of them
have said about Israel over the last
couple of years I mean Omar is a
disaster for Jewish people I can't
imagine if she has any Jewish people in
her district that they could possibly
vote for but what Omar has said what
Talib has said and then yesterday I
noticed for the first time to leave with
the tears all of a sudden she starts
with tears tears and I don't buy it
I don't buy it I don't buy it for a
second because I've seen her they vary
vicious mood at campaign rallies my
campaign rallies before she was a
congresswoman I said who is that and I
saw a woman that was violent and vicious
and out of control and all of a sudden I
see this person who's crying because she
can't see a grandmother she could see a
grandmother they gave her permission to
see her grandmother but she grant
Stanton and she didn't want to do it so
that's a decision of Israel that's not a
lot of people are saying that was my
decision that's a decision of Israel
they can let them in if they want but I
don't think they want to when you read
the things that they've said about
Israel how bad and if you look at their
itinerary before they found out you take
a look at their itinerary that was all
there to be a propaganda to her against
Israel so I don't blame Israel for doing
what they did I have nothing to do with
it but I don't blame them for doing what
they did I think it would have been very
bad to let them man including the four
I'm talking about all four but these two
that wanted to get in Omar and to leave
and I think would be a very bad thing
for Israel but Israel has to do what
they want to do but I would not cut off
aid to Israel and I can't even believe
that we're having this conversation five
years ago the concept of even talking
about this even three years ago of
cutting off aid to Israel because of two
people that hate Israel and hate Jewish
people I can't believe we're even having
this conversation where is the
Democratic Party God where have they
gone where they're defending these two
people over the State of Israel and I
think any Jewish people that vote for a
Democrat I think it shows either a total
lack of knowledge or a great disloyalty
all right thank you very much
thank you guys we're leaving now thank
you guys pitbull we're leaving out thank
you guys everybody thank you Steve
thanks